we need to get some League good food mmm
what's the league food gonna be official
liga legends food court order online i
set up an account are you kidding me man
i have to set up an account to order
food oh no just because of that pizza
nova i am not buying from you we're
going to pizza pizza two medium pizzas
for toppings combined two cans of coke
plus 24 when admission has a pretty
decent deal two medium pizzas I'll bigs
a medium pizza okay we're doing this to
meeting pieces for Tom Paine's four cans
of coke plus the two for one admission
that's what happens pizza nova you just
lost some business making me sign up an
account that's total garbage will be
themed I think you sign up an account
see well let's see what happens twin
medium or large what's a twin March it's
two twin large it's unclear but it
doesn't matter give me too okay well
this is a pretty cool thing you get to
see it too I'm gonna go with really
crooked on back neck let's see what
happens do that were you pretty it would
be pretty awesome okay oh I got a
question single no not the whole thing
there we go meet there we go buffalo
chicken
well there you go not lightly done well
done and gone with nothing okay continue
look at that oh but now you see this
picture then update okay no listen
aliasing so what you get whole great
option on the dope where's my whole
grain dope the only you are not able I'm
back did I just lose everything are you
kidding I think our last everyth we will
literally erase my heart at midnight you
know once upon a time people use the
phone to order pizza I'm not as happy
with my pizza on pizza nightmares are
going to do that again no special
instructions and continue we're gonna
make your pizza oh let's not mess it up
okay yeah how's our dope fine regular
don't jump sauce fun cheese young boy
doing ok convicts we're doing fantastic
yeah I'll get the fresh mushrooms on the
whole thing with the whole thing oh look
at you man and you want to meet the new
york pepper the whole thing you want to
happen have don't throw the whole thing
yeah and peppers yeah chile the whole
thing no italiano blend there you go and
chili peppers that's it okay continue
that's all I was it fast but I think I
kind of suffered through the learning
curve to make that happen for us I want
to barks what do you want what are your
two drinks neste nothing for continued
yeah and this is step two okay we're
gonna do delivery Oh guest checkout
second piece of Nova gasps check out
right there done so i'm holding up now
what if i don't have the phone number
what's the problem or a phone right they
can't call me i know i don't have it see
you never work yep okay here's what i
would like to pay hey take my eyes
credit card they have my fee for a debit
card but not a credit card that's
ridiculous order confirmation the order
was placed email confirmations been sent
normal now it gives you another create
account option which I do not want to do
thank you very much look at your order
will arrive in 40 minutes and is a
countdown good job Pizza Pizza cool good
job okay Pizza has a ride but with my
chip for one movie let's see whose is
whose this is Jason's pass the word to
look at that oh that's a pretty good man
good yeah good quick hand what that's
what I'm talking about Pizza Pizza my
new home